hey what's up welcome to another episode
of get close podcast i'm your co-host
geo i'm bart and today we have the big
big homie rubbing his nipple lottos it's
cold in here is it really yeah it is oh
we have the ac on real good so we don't
i never see
bart wood a jacket ever yo man he looks
so different out here he wears jackets i
don't wear jackets every day wow and
pants dude because i could actually wear
it without drenching it in sweat yes
i didn't even get to introduce them okay
joe's here
and it was so dope because last time we
were here we finally got to catch up
because i hadn't seen you in months um
and your life is so [ __ ] interesting
to me i go down your stories and i'm
always like what is he up to now and
you're like in this different country or
in this different state and you're doing
some crazy ass thing whether it's like
off-roading or hiking or mountain biking
or snowboarding and i'm like man this
guy is [ __ ] doing life right and it's
[ __ ] dope to witness thank you
i feel so funny right now please if
you're listening to the podcast please
watch the youtube because i look like a
vegas
uh like 70s pimp and it's a porn
producer yeah yes that's what i look
like
a rave club promoter
oh
i like that one i need a little bit more
glitter i feel like true okay so in this
video we're gonna change the format a
little bit and i asked uh my instagram
friends to ask you some questions so
none of these questions come from bart
and i okay so if if they're whack or
they're too invasive you gotta answer no
matter what okay let's go okay first one
joe
how japanese are you
i'm so japanese
how [ __ ] that what kind of question is
that
maybe they want to know like if you're
mixed or like maybe where you're from
like do you know i did it 23 and me and
i am 99
japanese that is crazy and then they
don't ever give you 100 on 23andme
anyway in case they're wrong yeah yeah
yeah i was 98 japanese and one percent
korean but then i checked up again it
got updated and then it's back to 99.
but doesn't japanese have like the most
um like on
like the most uh
what's the word uncircumcised yep they
have a lot of uncircumcised japanese no
like um like uh they just they're just
japanese homogeneous homogeneous yeah
there we go i think japan and maybe
iceland
are the two oh yeah iceland iceland is
even worse because like they have an app
that tells you if you're related to
something right i heard of that yeah so
you don't hook up with your cousin yeah
that's a that's kind of how japanese i
am okay is it because like you know
people that are like oh i'm third
generation second generation so people
oh yeah i'm second generation yeah once
they're like fourth generation they're
like i'm pretty much white
oh that's true that's true very true
well i speak it so maybe that gives me
some japanese points been to japan maybe
10 times now so that's a lot actually
japan boy
and uh
i don't know i don't know i'm japanese i
think you answered is your favorite food
japanese is that like your ghost top
three top three yeah what are the other
two
i would say like vietnamese oh i love
vietnamese food and then
steaks
hell yeah such as american or just
i love grilled steaks
okay next question
um oh okay would you ever do the west
coast specific trail if so how long do
you think uh you can last what's that
you don't know what that is no what is
that [ __ ] manny they're moving on maybe
it's like a mountain mountain biking
trail that i don't know of maybe do you
want to look it up or is it hiking is it
like you go through death valley or some
[ __ ] is it some crazy ass [ __ ] trails
west coast specific trail west
coast it sounds like pacific
it sounds like a challenge
you know like the alcatraz swim where
you like swim to outside like the oregon
trail i want to do the oregon trail
what's that the actual the there's an
actual organ trail you start in new york
oh it's literally kansas city
it's literally on the coast
like you go through the [ __ ] the the
so the pacific coast trail officially
designate uh designated as a pacific
crest national scenic trail is a long
distance hiking an equestrian trail
closely aligned with the highest portion
of the cascade and the sierra nevada
mountain ranges which lie 100 250 miles
east of the u.s pacific coast how long
is the length
um is it 100.
i just saw it oh come on
if it's a 100 mile hike that sounds kind
of fun well one 200 and sorry
2653 miles
you got to drive that then right i guess
so but this person thinks you can do it
well because me and darion darren knows
uh he introduced me to a buddy back in
boston yeah who
came to l.a on a bicycle oh [ __ ] that's
cross country on a bicycle so that
inspired us to go
why don't we go to like san francisco on
a bicycle one of these days are you are
you really planning on doing that yeah
we want to do it but we just never got
around to like planning to route oh [ __ ]
yeah that's tight well let us know how
that goes all right i want to do it but
i got taika unless i strap them on my
back put some little goggles on them you
know they get dogs and they have the dog
goggles i'll just get some of those for
taika put on my back we all go or give
them a little baby bike oh that's so
cute okay next question this is a good
one um how does bart and joe have a
healthy friendship and a r and uh are
running a successful business together
go watch the full on jk news where we
spent 30 minutes i'm just kidding you
guys just talked about that
yeah it's up
where is it it came up a couple weeks
ago on news or patreon no on news yeah
yeah one of the after record because
someone asked us like
about that
and well to summarize
i think like what we said was
um from the get we were just
it worked out that we were straight up
and then like we were always about the
cause and the group versus what we
personally wanted so like
the reason why our friendship probably
stayed true this long is because
we always put the goal of the group
first instead of personal gain ego or
anything and that's hard to do because
like sometimes you want you want to win
personally yeah but then i felt like i
was losing
by being selfish and i think maybe bart
same thing so it worked out because when
we fought it was because we thought
this would be better for the group
and it was never because like it's
better for me yeah right and i think
that's one thing the second thing is we
communicated
clearly so even if we had differences we
always said what we wanted
so then it we never felt like um
like you were holding back for someone
yeah yeah um and just working with both
of you guys it was really beautiful to
witness um because yeah you guys would
have your discussions about things and
disagreements
and i think that's very natural but you
guys i never saw you guys get heated
over anything and there was a lot of
back and forth because both of you guys
are very intellectual people um and and
you guys both have a vision and you guys
are both very strong in that vision but
like you said you guys had the why and
the goal in mind so everything kind of
like funneled to that but
yeah i had never i've never seen you
guys fight and i think that's [ __ ]
sick and i think
me and george is try it people yeah you
know it's like we can speculate all day
because most arguments are speculative
right it's like this is better that's
better well who the [ __ ] knows let's
just try it and we'll try it both ways
yeah and then so we'll try something my
way maybe i completely wrote something i
directed something or he writes it he
directs it and afterwards
we've never had i told you some moment
because it's really for the group so oh
yeah that was better for us you know or
that wasn't better for us so it's i
think we [ __ ] up we just [ __ ] up and
it's like don't do that again you know
yeah yeah what's the big deal i don't
know why it's so hard for people to get
along but
i can see it now like just by running
companies and like having a team and
seeing why it's like oh we got lucky
dude yeah yeah because you guys are both
uh very mature people
um and you're both very logical and you
guys know how to clearly communicate and
i think those three things
um
a lot of people don't carry you say we
were mature
you know you know what i mean like
you're mature when it matters yeah and
you just you and you're playful i think
people seem like people's egos get the
best of them a lot of times and then
they and they don't even know so what
they think they're fighting for is
actually like a chip on their shoulder
or something like that where i think
like one of the biggest tests was when
me and joe auditioned for the bring back
of in living color
yeah and this was probably 2011 or
something like that 2013 and that was
like the biggest pivot point in our life
we could have ditched everyone and said
we're going on this show and got like
what was it like it was like 10 grand
episode or some [ __ ] it was like 30 g's
an episode 30 grand together yeah and
then it was guaranteed 13 episodes the
first so within like we would have made
like 300 g's and that's when we were
making like a thousand bucks a month
yeah it would have made 300 g's within
like six months and then i think in the
contract if that does well immediately
two or three seasons after that and it
was that versus our thousand dollars a
month youtube channel but we had a
little family that we really cared about
yeah and that was like one of the
hardest decisions we were even even
thinking about what if one of us goes on
the show one of us stays back to run to
youtube
we're like we're really yeah we're
really
it was weird that both of us got picked
on the audition that is crazy i thought
they were just going to choose one asian
dude but they wanted both yeah and i was
like what
that's cool there's a ton of people
auditions like white people black people
hispanic whatever yeah and yeah they
they chose both of us
and that was tough but it was always for
us it was always been like the team's
well-being and we made the right choice
because the the show didn't even air no
they didn't like it and yeah way more
money yeah because they never aired yeah
yeah they aired maybe they would have
won
you know but or maybe if we were on they
would have aired
oh who knows man who knows what would
have happened yeah but so many things
the it's not that i don't think we don't
have an ego i think we actually have big
egos but it's expressed in a different
form so it's like it's more like a
long-term ego where it's like no i'm
doing this for the group
because like instead of going and and
servicing another like business like
like if it was snl or whatever right
instead of making them rich we're like
no [ __ ] that like we're gonna make our
group
right so it's like expressed in a way
where like we're the baddest yeah versus
like i am and i it's all from it's all
about me yeah well and you guys have
immense loyalty to each other
um which is also very [ __ ] rare
very very rare the older i get the more
i see um loyalty isn't something that's
um not a lot of people view it the same
way yeah you know that's what i realized
it's like
i mean we threw around this word too
like family and loyalty and whatever but
then
everyone's family is different like the
way that
you know like some parents they cheat
their kids and like some
siblings they constantly lie and like
the standards in one family doesn't
apply to another yeah and then so like
we have this idea of what it should be
but then
it's so freaking different depending on
how you grew up yeah so like even
loyalty and like
you know certain things that you think
you shouldn't do other people are like
no that's fine like right yeah that's
true yeah everyone's definition of
loyalty is different too because like uh
someone that grew up on the streets
versus someone that grew up in a more
affluent neighborhood their versions of
loyalty are completely different so
very very true
okay but now y'all are [ __ ] it was
rad witnessing the friendship and the
and how you guys run businesses it was
very inspiring and i hate giving you
guys compliments
i hate it too
don't act like you weren't a part of
that journey yeah i mean but like you
guys created it you know what i mean
like i can i am a part of a journey and
i and i and i did contribute to it i
don't deny that but like um there needed
to be leadership you know and without
the if the leadership is already
sketched then it doesn't last as long as
it it did you know
or it has because it's not it hasn't
ended yeah um okay next question
what is the crazy this for you joe okay
uh what is the craziest thing you have
done for someone out of love
out of love
he's so offended why the [ __ ] are you
guys asking this question he's offended
i have no idea i think this is one of
those questions that someone has to
answer for me because a lot of the
things that i do i feel are completely
normal
you know like
have you ever
uh
flown somewhere on a whim
like come [ __ ] this [ __ ] right now and
you just fly there
that's pretty that's that's pretty crazy
i think is it
yeah i don't know have you i don't know
if it's out of love it's obvious i don't
know if that's all right
my definition love is different
i think i've heard you um i think i've
heard stories of you like completely
accepting the your significant others um
and this is i'm i'm combining a lot of
significant others that i've i mean i've
known you for [ __ ] yeah ever dude oh
my god i think i've known you for like
15 years if not longer um wow so yeah
the combination of significant others
that you've had in our in in our
friendship time
i've seen you
take on a lot of their
burdens and responsibilities and their
debts and [ __ ] and like you've you've
like really carried them out of a lot of
dark places and [ __ ] and that's maybe
that's intense man yeah even when i
didn't love them
[Laughter]
so that is the true form to his form of
love you're giving love that's
selflessness
i don't even love your ass anymore
goddammit i'm dealing with this [ __ ]
yeah you you've you you really give it
your all in a relationship i do think
that's a test of love like it's i don't
think the true test of love is during
happy times i think it's during when
it's dark and it's real 100
that's the true test of love yeah in
every relationship whether it's just
want to mention kick them to the curb
and throw them away yeah but you can't
just like yeah but i can't do that yeah
make it work
all right next question okay i'm gonna
combine two of these because they uh
they're similar yeah they're very
similar okay so um are do you foresee
yourself being a dad in 2022 no it's too
early holy [ __ ] i don't know man people
want it the people want to know that's
[ __ ] fascinating i've always said i
was always down to have kids if i had
tons of money and people to take care of
that right yeah you could have them
yeah you said you want to have them and
then have other people take care of them
yeah but then
you know the stars aren't aligned for me
it would have been it would have been
2009 that i had a kid or whatever
because i was busting nuts baby
i'm lucky is what i'm saying it's like i
didn't
could've happened
i'll bust the nuts baby
[Laughter]
oh my god okay uh and then i guess the
next one that i'm gonna combine is when
when do you think that you'll be married
if that's even in the cards for you
i don't know
good i have no idea good for you man
yeah it's going with the flow yeah and i
really really i really love what's going
on right now you know it's it's cool it
already feels like i'm married i don't
know you know just
it's a weird kind of
place that's tight that's awesome it
doesn't sound weird at all it sounds
like it's the right place to be at the
right time but i think it is something
that will eventually happen like i'm not
opposed to the idea of marriage or
anything like that yeah and your taxes
are going to be [ __ ] exactly
this podcast is sponsored by
ziprecruiter okay so if you're looking
to hire anyone on your team you have to
have to have to have to try zip
recruiter i've tried it multiple times
and it's been a lifesaver not only is it
a lifesaver but it's super quick
efficient and time saving i absolutely
love all three of those things so if
this sounds like something that's right
up your alley then please
don't go away listen because zip
recruiter is gonna save you so much time
and headache i promise you that okay so
zippercutter uses powerful technology to
find and match the right candidates
with your job okay they're proactively
seeking out um
potential candidates and sending them
your way okay so once these candidates
are sent your way you're not getting
bombarded with a ton of notifications or
a bunch of emails everything is nicely
and neatly sorted for you you can go in
depth and read every single line that
you want person to person or they have
like this quick review system where you
look at the resumes you either thumbs it
down thumbs it up thumbs it down or kind
of maybe if you're kind of on the fence
about the person
then
you just sort from your thumbs up and
maybe your maybes and then you start
reaching out to these people
it's
that simple like
i don't even want to complicate it it's
really that simple so it really is no
wonder why ziprecruiter is
the number one
rated hiring site in the u.s okay for
everyone listening right now
specifically for those of you looking
for um more candidates to add to your
team
find the right employees for your
workplace with zip recruiter try it for
free
yes try it for free at
uh zipruter.com
get close again
it's ziprecruiter.com
get close g-e-t
c-o-l-s-e
thanks
okay ironically enough please if you
didn't catch the first interview uh or
just not interview but podcast that we
had with joe please check that out
because we do talk about this briefly
but someone wants to know it's like they
were in our conversation before it even
happened is when are you visiting india
india
i know
you know what's crazy so um
you know cami right
she used to hang out with like a bunch
of the girls like um anyways yeah so
maybe not so um cami's one of our our
friends
from um back in the day and she used to
work at this bar car called cafe blue
and then um she disappeared for for a
minute and then like we kind of
connected again and then she basically
like [ __ ] off to india because one of
her
cousins was like yeah come through like
and then what her cousin does is like he
just buys all these like motorcycles and
then they do these trips so she
she went up the himalayas she rode all
over india and she keeps selling it to
me she's like one of these days you got
to go with me and then like
we got a ride through the himalayas and
i'm like that sounds freaking crazy and
she showed me pictures and everything
and like
i'm like
yeah you got me sold i want to [ __ ]
go oh cool yeah that's good before that
it was like taj taj mahal and whatever
but almost all of my friends that's been
to india they're like i don't know man
like but then the way she sold it to me
was completely different yeah because
she's like it's different when you're
like
writing as a group on the open road and
you're just going wherever you want yeah
i'm like all right that does sound tight
because it sounds like you're doing like
the back country stuff of uh opposed to
like all the touristy [ __ ] where like
it's high crime and like they kind of
prey on the tourists i like that too but
i don't know
i want to ride through the himalayas
that sounds amazing i want to get
pickpocketed i want to get all that
i want a monkey to steal my apple like
come on man that is cool you wear a
bunch of like [ __ ] glittery shits all
the monkeys are attracted to you yeah
they're [ __ ] violent okay side side
track but have you heard i think it's
happening in india right now there's a
war
between pakistan i think oh pakistan
you're right uh between monkeys and dogs
you know there's a bunch of stray dogs
um yeah so these monkeys are [ __ ]
getting a vengeance because uh the dogs
killed one of their monkeys so now the
[ __ ] monkeys are picking up stray
dogs taking them up to the roof of like
houses and throwing them off buildings
like over a hundred dogs have died that
way there's like a [ __ ] war happening
dog war dude and then they're starting
to fight the humans too because i think
the humans are getting pissed about it
because they're like don't throw the
dogs yeah wow yeah it's crazy i want to
go to pakistan now and check that out
okay
next question man the people love joe
as a fellow former adventist
uh i admire your resilience in your life
and company oh this is not a question
they just want a compliment all right uh
in company and comedy and friends
that's it yeah they [ __ ] adore you
okay this comes from the homie son that
mike the brother the fam hell yeah he
had to contribute this is what he had to
ask you okay
at what age did you develop your
confidence and free spirit always
admired that uh that about you it's
funny because like it's only
you know in recent years that i keep
hearing
these things about oh you're free spirit
you don't give a [ __ ] whatever right
maybe people have told me before you've
always but it just went over my head
yeah because i never felt
um that i developed it
you know what i mean like it's it's all
natural
yeah like i'm just like i'm just me and
then like and then and then i'm getting
rewarded and praised
and it's so weird but
you've felt that way ever since you're a
kid or do you feel like you have to
unleash it
i feel like
i've been more true to myself now than i
was before so like
um i've been this way like probably in
elementary school whatever and then
there was a point in time maybe like
late junior high high school where i
became extremely self-conscious and
there was a time when um
i got really into like drugs and [ __ ]
and then
i didn't feel normal unless i was on
something so like if i wasn't stoned if
i wasn't whatever and then when i was
sober i felt really insecure and like it
got to it got to the point where i
couldn't eat at restaurants
like i was so anxious and then i barely
ate i didn't have an appetite i was
eight in my room i was in high school is
it because you felt like everyone was
just watching you yeah i thought people
it's the paranoia you know when you're
not smoking weed or maybe you're on weed
but you think people are watching i'm on
acid and i'm like everyone's like i
remember walking by a school bus full of
children unloading and then i thought
they were all staring at me and telling
on me at the teacher that i'm [ __ ] up
so like i went through like a really
weird mental
stage of like too much drugs too much
paranoia
and then so like i
wasn't maybe comfortable
and then i was afraid of like i even
wasn't i couldn't even talk in front of
the uh
my class and all that even when we're
doing jk i can't even picture that yeah
like being myself wow in front of the
class i was shaking so like oh yeah i
remember you had a speech class and you
were telling me about you're giving me a
speech and it was so [ __ ] hard it was
hard but then we would be doing shows in
front of a thousand people and i'm
completely comfortable with the costume
on too yeah
yeah we were it was so hard for us to
even vlog back then yeah
yeah and jk knew when we first did it we
weren't we weren't ourselves
yeah but
maybe youtube is what eased me into it
we're just playing and playing and
playing and then whatever but
for the longest time though just
something in college when i sobered up
when i just started
being bored out of my mind because i you
know drugs it just feels good so then
chasing that
feel of like
just going out and being having fun
sober i think that's where i'm like oh
maybe that shows us confidence but
that's just that's just like uh
maybe interpreted that way
yeah
because like i'm anxious so i
i i have fun and i am loud and i am
talking to cover up that anxiety wow do
you still have that now where your high
anxiety
i don't think so yeah yeah but i think
that's where my hyperactivity came from
and my loudness and my craziness i think
it came from
me actually being anxious and i don't
like to hear quiet and all that and i
like noise because it made me feel good
yeah yeah because ever since i've known
you you were always loud
so i remember you were the loud person
in the homie circle
um and this was before jk or maybe like
right at the beginning yeah that's
college
oh and that's when you started yeah
because i i wasn't i was already sobered
up by then so it was toward high school
at the end of high school yeah oh damn
damn
okay
um thank you silent mike appreciate the
question okay another question why not
grow out the beard with a long hair
i tried it and then like
sometimes i want to snorkel and then the
oh it gets in the way yeah yeah yeah
that's it that's impractical yeah do you
plan on cutting the hair ever it's up to
hannah i told her i was like you choose
you want to do something to my hair go
ahead but then like
i want it to be
you know based off of what you think but
then eventually i told her that if it
gets long enough i'm going to partner up
with like a cancer foundation and just
shave it and then give it to somebody
that was yeah yeah you have the virgin
hair
yeah it hasn't been colored or anything
it's not perfect um why are you leaving
it up to hannah why not up to you you
just don't care enough
yeah it
this is actually the easiest time i've
had with my hair like the only annoying
thing is like when it's wet right or
like if i want to swim and all that what
happens when it's wet
so just say if you're swimming it'll
like blow up
or like it just takes forever to dry
after a shower i see i never had that
problem and then it gets cold or
something yeah but i haven't had a
haircut since
march 20 20. oh [ __ ] yeah damn and you
have that thick ass hair like for people
with thick hair the back here won't dry
until [ __ ] forever so you're just
like it's damp for maybe even the whole
day whoa yeah it takes a minute yeah it
does we can relate on like
what kind of hair products do you use
but it's it's so easy yeah i didn't
realize how [ __ ] easy and then like
getting a haircut like every two weeks
and there's that awkward phase where
like if your care grew up a little bit
you look familiar yeah
it doesn't grow out at the same rate
either it's like this i hate it i hate
that i know because i used to go to bar
in your barber
so you know that side hair feeling right
yeah yeah yeah gets cold like if it's a
cold day and you're like oh [ __ ] it's
cold no i never get that i like i like
when it feels cold oh really yeah it
feels fresh like i love it i feel like i
just took a shower or something i hate
it
okay so uh you just talked about hannah
hannah's your girlfriend and um someone
is asking is she the one
probably oh i think no i think she is
yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and the reason why i
say that never heard that i'd never do
do
do
the first time i feel
like um
i can be who i am in a better version of
who i am with the person oh that's
awesome because in the past it's always
been a compromise yeah of like maybe
they have to be the person that i want
them to be and vice versa like we're
both changing yeah and that doesn't work
yeah and then you know like we just have
to go through these experiences to know
like
uh the difference of
loving someone for their flaws and
everything and then like feeling
accepted and loved by verse vice versa
for just being who you are and like i
think those things
it's not natural and it's rare and then
like i think most relationships you have
to learn to love where like you have to
you have to mold right and i don't think
there's a right or wrong way but this is
the first experience where i feel
comfortable and i don't maybe like i
don't feel pressured to be different
cool yeah well you've also evolved a lot
right like like we've all evolved like
the like the geo that you knew when we
first met is dead yeah like the bart
that you knew when you guys first met is
that like like you're no longer the same
joe that i meant like you've evolved and
you've you've changed so much
um i want to say with even even within
like the last
five years you're just such a different
person like back then you were a little
bit more um reserved a little bit like
reserved is [ __ ] funny but you were
like
you you had it felt like you had these
walls that like at least at least that i
felt yeah um that i just i didn't know
how to get past it so i was like oh okay
i guess that's just joe joe's just the
guarded person yeah um
and and within those five years it was
like you were just a lot more emotional
and a lot more expressive and like um
even making eye contact was something
that like
i i wouldn't catch from you and like
you're just such a different vibe now
you are so like um
yes it has to do with the person and the
compatibility and stuff but i think it
also
mainly has to do with just you being
comfortable with yourself and and doing
whatever work you did that's true
because we we say that like
if we met like maybe just even two three
years ago we probably wouldn't be
attracted to each other yeah it was like
good timing where like we both evolved
to meet each other at the right time and
i think that's a big part of it too
because it's like if we knew each other
even five years ago we'd be attracted
maybe physically so we might be [ __ ]
buddies but then would we be good like
do we see each other as like a partner
yeah in a long-term way and it's like
probably not what is it about the three
to five years ago where you guys
wouldn't have hit it off um the state of
mind that she was in i was in so like
for me i think
that i was still working through a lot
of [ __ ]
and um
my view of a lot of things and how i
approach people and how i communicated
wasn't like i think it's the past
relationships that helped me become who
i am in a relationship yeah so yeah all
those lessons i learned so now i'm a
better
to deal with
for
for a lot of [ __ ] like i'm not i'm not
gonna approach it the way that i did
before and then same for her right so
like
it's almost like we made all these
mistakes elsewhere and then like we
learned from it and then now we get to
give that so i it just worked out that's
awesome yeah no that's that's [ __ ]
great um
no i [ __ ] i'm like taking it back a
little bit um i thought joe was just
gonna be like the free spirit dude that
like
um is just constantly out to like
explore and experience explore and push
it all over the world if you want to say
the [ __ ] all over the [ __ ] slayer all
over the world for sure but i just saw
you as someone and not just not to take
away that you can't do that now yeah but
that was just my vision of you i didn't
really see you um
i feel like no but you're not right
though because
i'm the same i i thought the same thing
about myself like
it's not something that i was
going to go for like a relationship and
i'm not i don't think i'm a relationship
type like we have yeah so cute because
all your relationships have been very
long term
yeah i know you're a very serial
relationship person dude and then i've
hated all of them like i'm like why am i
in there
like
i'm like why am i in these situations
you know like this is not who i am i
think you're also committed and loyal
too so i have yeah i think
i have a problem of sticking two things
way too long because i think i could
make it better
it's like i should have let go way long
ago yeah but then when i was being
single i was like oh i love this and i'm
actually her first boyfriend so like
she's not as committed in the sense
where like you know like
i i don't think i was that emotionally
committed to the people i was with so i
might physically be with them yeah but
they all will feel like roommates and
[ __ ] buddies for a long time instead of
like emotionally deep and like
progressing in that romantic way right
so then
that's where i feel like oh i i'm not
that committed
um or i don't i don't i'm not maybe a
relationship person because i wasn't
lovey-dovey and all that stuff so
i always thought well if this one
doesn't work you know maybe maybe i
should just like have like [ __ ] buddies
and then like be single and then like
even for hannah she was like yeah i
think like that was a perfect
arrangement for me like she's career
driven she likes
sticking to her hobbies and whatever so
i was like i think that's
where we both were
and then and then it kind of fell into
place like oh
i'm actually more comfortable with you
than i am with myself now
that's [ __ ] cool man
evolution i love it i love it yeah in a
relationship you don't have to be
lovey-dovey it's really up to whatever
terms you want it to be just as long as
it feels good yeah um i've had
girlfriends that i've talked to where
they're like
man i compare my relationship to these
other this other couple and like i see
how they are and they're so lovey-dovey
and they're affectionate and they're you
know hugging and and being physical and
stuff and like you know i i fear i can't
give that to my significant other and
i'm like well are you both happy yeah
she's like yeah we're really happy and
is that what they want like exactly
and and it was one of those where it's
like i don't think he even cares like i
think he's really happy with what you
guys have and like comparing it is like
useless because that's them and this is
you guys and you guys have been together
for [ __ ] like over a decade it's the
whole like love language thing right
like some people express it differently
and i was always under the impression
that i'm not romantic because of the
people
that i dated so the girls that i were i
was with their love language is
different so i might be expressing
romantic things but to them it's not
received that way right so when i got
with hannah she thinks i'm extremely
romantic
because
it's her language too cute so give me an
example i want a hero
i'm very spontaneous right and i like to
have fun and i'm not putting her in her
butt and she loves it
very spontaneous like
i'm just naturally me
and i want to
have quality time with her right not
just be like oh you know be awesome
today let's do this all right um
and what's this is it like a picnic or
is it like let's go pick up [ __ ] car
parts let's go grab some
food and then we'll go to the beach and
i know this cool place we could have
some hammocks
yeah yeah and then
i've done that with almost all of my
exes but they never found it romantic
it's just we're just playing or like
it's not the right environment or
whatever it is yeah yeah i'm like i do
this with my guy friends too
so i'm like am i really being romantic i
don't know like yeah i think it is her
love language she sees that you're
planning and you're caring about having
a good time and the good time is shared
between you two and she sees it that way
versus someone else might just see like
oh like joe just wants to go explore and
i guess i'm the tag along person or
whatever yeah maybe so it just fits
where
who i am naturally she finds it as like
thoughtful caring romantic
we're like i'm like i do this with my
guy friends too but hey say that dude
don't say that and then like if it is
the right person they'll perceive it as
like well yeah that's cool that you do
it with your guy friends too but it's
still different because it's us yeah
yeah so she sees the effort she sees all
that stuff and then so
it's pretty awesome because she's
teaching me like and in the past i was
so blind to what romantic was like
remember when we had those jk um
circle talks right yeah yeah and then we
were talking about and i i it went over
my head i'm like this is too complex
maybe i'm just unemotional and i don't
know what romantic things are
and then it didn't help that i was with
partners
who felt
that my lack of expression
means that they're unloved so then they
get insecure and then they get mad at me
right so then it creates this like cycle
of like
um i want to learn and i'm not against
it but then now i feel like
there's like now it turns into an
argument yeah it's like well [ __ ] it
then i don't know what to do and i'm not
good enough
but then when you're in environment or
like when you're with someone who
understands what you're trying to do
and then also like i don't know it's a
different loving approach yeah the more
it's more effortless yeah so um it feels
like
oh cool like i'm understood but then
yeah oh i love that man that's [ __ ]
tight because that shit's hard
it's really hard
yeah if you're not with the right person
like i've never felt
more free um like even though we've had
our ups and downs and we've talked about
a relationship on so many different
platforms of like us like almost getting
divorced and just the shittest [ __ ]
shittiest relationship we've ever had
but in the beginning when we first got
together like i had never felt so free
like i always felt like um
i had to like be this other person that
i thought i needed to be to be up to par
to make him happy yeah um or or like i
thought that's what a relationship was
like you have to be this way but when i
met him i was completely accepted for
everything that i was yeah um whether
that's just something surface like the
way i dressed um the way i carried
myself my thoughts
even let you have that man haircut
that's straight
truth feels like i'm [ __ ] a dude
sometimes
you said that
you said that maybe
no but i felt like i just felt like like
you just said like i could be myself
and i had never experienced that like
with any relationship and i'm not even
speaking romantically i just felt like
in any relationship i could never just
be well makes sense because you said you
grew up with so many rules and i can
relate to that like and it's like you
can't you're so
you're taught to like please others
first before your own right or else
you're being selfish yeah so then like
because my mom was hella controlling too
so she was just like no no you gotta
be considerate don't do this don't do
that
and then your mind gets so wired to like
think of oh that might bother them they
might not like this yeah and then you
lose your sense of like wait what do you
want yeah yeah i can't believe you think
that
i can't believe you've had that thought
process um because i like i always say
right like you're such a free spirit and
we just talked about it and you're like
where does this come from like i've
always been this way um so the idea or
the thought that you have that in your
mind
is is yeah i just have to get used to it
i think to it
it didn't last long so i could relate
because i felt so controlled and how
like my mom is similar she was so but
then
you know how like you say like your mom
is still that way my mom had her own
growth where she she's no longer that
way so then i'm lucky that she
saw that and she was like oh [ __ ]
i'm controlling him too much
for no reason you know and then so like
i think i got lucky where she stopped
doing that to me and i was able to just
be myself oh that's so sick yeah that's
so sad mine's the opposite i'm like i
see how annoying my mom is she still has
friends i'm like oh even annoying people
could have friends
and tight friends too
she could fart at my boy scout meetings
and do all that stuff because people
still like her your mom is down as [ __ ]
she is down though i think you obviously
have your traumatic experiences with her
it's your own relationship but yeah your
mom is such a dope person like she's
super positive like this is my
experience with her she's super positive
always positive she's very down for the
[ __ ] overall like uh the vibe of the
group yeah she's always looking out for
everybody if the plan is good enough
she'll sell her house to make it happen
yeah like i've never felt like a
second-class citizen
um
in that house she's not judgmental she's
very accepting yeah because most i feel
like most asian moms are so [ __ ]
critical and judgmental yeah like god
dang dude yeah i've heard it i've never
experienced it firsthand luckily um but
yeah your mom has like since day one i
felt like i was already part of the
family so your mom's dope she's got a
lot of love but then she's controlling
in a different way i think she's goal
driven that's her control it's not like
fear but it's of of judgment but it's
more like she wants something she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about what you feel
she wants it yeah she's gonna get it
yeah and her standards are really high
which i think is dope as [ __ ] too
because she's like a single woman in a
country she doesn't know english or the
language she raised your [ __ ] crazy
ass like
if you were anything like taika and you
say you're worse than taika owns two
homes yeah
yeah [ __ ] your mom's your mom's stellar
as [ __ ] you should give her more credit
um but i [ __ ] love that for you i
love that you've found the person that
can let you be yourself because
like i could try thinking about it
better too yeah i like each other better
which is awesome yeah
yeah it's pretty cool it's and it's and
it's not even intentional that's what
that's i think it's like it kind of fell
on our laps yeah i was like oh [ __ ] i
mean i really like her too man like i i
i like when i first met her like her her
vibe her energy just her she just didn't
feel like she's trying to be any type of
way she just feels very comfortable to
be around
um she has this very warm uh like
nurturing like energy to her like she's
really cool i really really like her the
moral the stories get with people that
work through their [ __ ]
yeah that's true well no the more of the
story is work through your own [ __ ] i
love yourself yes so you can recognize
when people haven't worked through this
[ __ ] that's what that tells you that's
true so all of your partners that you
said that you hated and i know you're
joking around like i know it's a big
joke but it's really comes from you
because you picked them so it's a
hundred percent
you that was the issue there yeah no
you're 100 right yeah because i i think
that
yeah like it's like i didn't work
through my [ __ ] yeah i couldn't
recognize and i was
also so optimistic to the point where
i think it's a bit of narcissism but
it's like it's like no i'm so [ __ ]
positive i can change you that's what my
mentality was
so it's like oh you might have these
flaws but like you stick around with me
for long enough i'm gonna fix you and
then
that's not the truth because people are
they have their own ideas they're you
know and it's like and then sometimes
their thought process can bleed into
mind right and i didn't i didn't think
about that and who's to say that that
issue is even an issue and it's probably
just your issue yeah it could be yeah
and a lot of the times it's like
why am i trying to control that it's
like who cares if that's who they are
why can't i love them for who they are
you know yeah yeah so
that's [ __ ] dope that's awesome yeah
look at that i [ __ ] love it dude i'm
so [ __ ] excited for you this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp online
therapy okay betterhelp is an online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to and you
don't have to leave the comfort of your
own home also what i absolutely love
about better help is that you're talking
to a licensed professional
and you're given access to
a therapist that you might not even have
access to in your direct area some some
of you guys might live in a rural area
where you have very limited resources so
the fact that
better help is something that now you
have access to is amazing because we
have to remember
we have to work on our relationship with
ourselves we are our biggest assets
because how many times have we reached
out to to rush over to to be a crying
shoulder for a friend you know or not a
crying shoulder be a shoulder for a
friend that's in need we're constantly
doing so much for other people but when
it comes time for
us to do that for ourselves
we find it hard
really guilty here i'm speaking for
myself also um so the fact that better
help is out there to to just help you
sort out some thoughts is absolutely
amazing
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours give it a try and see
why over 2 million people have used
better help online therapy like i said
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and get close listeners are going to get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
get close that's b-e-t-t
dot com slash get close
okay um on the topic of hannah uh have
you had uh have you ate the full english
breakfast whatever that is what is that
was that eating her [ __ ]
that's not what that means
i think it's like they eat the beans and
the tomato i've had english breakfast is
that a continental breakfast
no that's frosted flakes
yeah european breakfast is something i
have to get used to because i'm i know
the [ __ ] fat ass american diet of the
[ __ ] lumberjack
um and then when we go to europe it's
like tomatoes i like baking beans yeah
sometimes you get a couple of like
hard-boiled eggs and then some sausages
it's good though i eat that every day
it's simple i don't think they eat
breakfast like us like i think they just
eat like a croissant and a coffee or
something yeah they're not [ __ ]
[ __ ] obese like american breakfast is
crazy they got it's bad they had french
toast and now they combine cinnamon roll
with french toast
it's crazy but it's delicious it's the
best
okay next question uh what does a tattoo
on your chest read mudaboo [ __ ]
and then they would
and it's actually mother bush it with
the with the question mark okay so
they're saying this is the same one
i didn't wanna i didn't want to forget
how it's written in japanese and in two
that was like symbolism of like
i i'm not gonna carry my father's last
name and i'm gonna carry my grandmas
yeah and then isn't there a funny story
my grandma's last name is actually ito
because she had a divorce and that
didn't change her name oh so he's killed
my grandpa so like i wanted to honor my
grandma yeah because she had two
daughters and no one to carry the name
so i said i'll carry that name for you
not knowing until after i get the tattoo
after i change my name she goes
oh that's not my maiden name and i'm
like i had this whole
talk with you of why i'm doing it the
meaning and all that so you talked to
her before you even got it done yeah she
goes the name's cool i decided to keep
it cause i'm not wrong but then also i
have a feeling that she loved my grandpa
because um when she had alzheimer's she
was still in love with him so like wow
while she was not you know
while she was you know
before she had dementia alzheimer's and
all that you know she would never
mention him whatever whatever but when
she got alzheimer's she's like my
husband's coming home soon and then he
would talk she would talk about him and
all that cute yeah
and it's like
i heard that um you know the divorce
came because he be he was a he was an
alcoholic and a frequent visitor of the
brothels
and then my mom was like yeah even
though he was an alcoholic he was a
happy drunk and he was a great father
like he was happy he was fun and she
goes honestly my mom is such a big
[ __ ] [ __ ] meaning my grandma she
probably drove him insane
she said your grandma's also very
educated which is rare strong yeah she's
very
strong in the sense where she willed
she loves debating she's like oh jesus
yeah so like sounds like a [ __ ]
tone it down over there dude you love
debating too no it just sounds too
familiar
but she basically fought with almost
every
person in my family um i know that
except for me
wait are you talking about me or your
mom no i'm just not because you have two
very strong independent [ __ ] stellar
females
and both have like don't know how to
dress either
you guys got the same style actually
watch in five years you're gonna have
[ __ ] gloves all the way up to here
i mean the sun is kind of harsh out here
crazy visors
real talk though your mom looks really
nice when she gets dressed up like baby
shower like if it's an occasion
she gets really nice okay when she can
she's like let me go her style's nuts
granted she has her [ __ ] visor but
she looks dope so funny i'm all trying
to save face here i'm like she looks
good dude
um
oh grandma okay so that's what it means
um i mean at least it's in japanese and
it says what you wanted it to say yeah
i'm in front of bart's my mom's like
it's cool that you kept it because she's
like it's still mine too because i
didn't know my mom never changed her
last name my grandma never changed her
last name and my mom was like i have no
reason to change it he was a great
father and she's like you know i would
you know she still had them in her life
you know and then she's like i loved him
and he was nice and and so she's like
yeah like he was he would drink a lot
but she's like he was never bad violent
whatever cool are you going to get it
too
right on this side jessica was a [ __ ]
dope [ __ ] last name man
better than [ __ ] i mean i like my
last name my last name
i'm glad it's just kyle because it would
have been ik films
[Laughter]
if that would that wouldn't have a ring
to it
yeah yeah it's not the same okay um i
know you we another one please check out
the first podcast it's so good uh we
briefly talked about a business that
you're potentially opening up in hawaii
people that are curious i know you don't
want to talk about it but is there
anything that you do want to kind of
like
leak hint
it's going to be in town so all of
everyone that's like where is it going
to be it's going to be in town for all
of you hawaii locos you know where that
is is there a projected month
no hopefully okay
um it would have been open in january
but let's just say
permitting is a [ __ ]
especially right now everything's
[ __ ] slow man and then they run on
hawaii time in hawaii and it's even
worse oh it's even slower
um okay all right like these goddamn
punctual mainlanders
i'm trying to see if i can pull anything
else out but i think that's all we're
gonna get yeah okay well then uh are you
gonna be promoting it like on your on
your instagram and like everybody okay
cool yeah okay and then um
i mean i mean the whole reason is like
it's my excuse to to finally live in
hawaii because like you know we always
talk about like we gotta live there you
know and then i'm like well i'm gonna do
this now hell yeah
man hell yeah i can't wait to visit
um okay
uh what happened to the mushroom farm
it's still there so like my
business partner josh um he you know
expanded from the east coast so he has a
mushroom farm out there and then now he
just got one in california and his
operations growing and whatever and um
we did suffer a little bit with the
shippings and and then the the supplies
like everybody else yes
yes but we're back on board you know
we're selling the kids and all that but
they sell out quick so
gotta get them who who get who's buying
these kits just anyone that wants to
cook who's like your mom yeah um
i don't know really like now it's just
organic like it's word of mouth there's
people searching it's like repeat
customers people that want to buy it for
their friends and family and it's like
a lot of different walks of life like
you have people who want fresh mushrooms
like so our main product is the mushroom
kit
um for e-commerce right so like
a lot of the people just curious and
like want the experience and then people
who like cooking want fresh produce
right so like
it just depends some people don't even
eat them they just want to watch them
grow yeah yeah so what is it explain it
for those that don't know what it is oh
so the so
basically we have this shiitake mushroom
kit it's called the mini mushroom farm
where you could bring the farm into your
own home right and it's a whole kit
where you can grow it and it you don't
need any dirt
all you need is a it all comes with
everything inside the box and it's easy
to go yeah there's like
yeah there's like a log i remember and
then there's like a like a there's a
spray there's a thermometer humidity
yeah there's a humid humid humidity
humidity
yeah yeah
you could check the levels and then you
could watch it like like literally come
to life and then you can harvest it and
cook with it and you're saying you could
see mushrooms within the hour right yeah
within the hours you sent us a kit yeah
and i was so impressed so the box is
really [ __ ] cool it had everything it
has all the directions it's like an
idiot like me i don't i don't have a
green thumb at all i don't [ __ ] cook
i don't understand how any of this [ __ ]
works like born and raised in the city i
don't get it
i get it uh it tells me to or i get the
package it tells me to add
let it soak in water and then you put
the humidity
in there and then it just start the next
day we had it yeah and you just sprayed
i was like it's super easy this is
[ __ ] cool yeah i gotta get one for
tyga oh yeah that would be fun i would
love that yeah yeah okay we gotta get
that where can i get it
uh at the
mushroomkingfarm.com sick all right you
guys heard that too
um
okay so you're still involved in that
yeah sick look at you okay uh
how does he uh i'm not gonna ask that
one but uh how does he budget or how do
you budget to live life
the way you're living it uh because your
travel goals
um a lot of
people think that i'm spending like
thousands and thousands of dollars when
i go travel
but
i'm actually
you know not spending that much at all
because what i do is i travel hack like
i look for the deals like if you look
for flight deals you know on off seasons
and if you look you know for like a a
flight on a weekday and
and it works because of my lifestyle
meaning like if i if i worked like a
regular job job
then all of my vacations are at the same
time when everyone else has break that's
when it's expensive peak season right
exactly but if you like let's say travel
on a wednesday
during you know
when no one's going to hawaii or
whatever yeah that's june's a good one i
found a round-trip ticket for like a
little over a hundred bucks what yeah to
where hawaii what the wow
that's so cool so like even even when i
island hop right like let's say i go to
maui i found a ticket for like 35 bucks
one way what yeah so like unless less
than 80 bucks i did a round-trip ticket
i also use credit card points so like if
you're gonna buy things anyway like
let's say
you're gonna buy groceries whatever
right you get a really good rewards card
that has a lot of like uh points on it
and then you can redeem them and it's
basically free because it's
you're gonna spend the money anyway you
might as well rack up points right
and um i couch surf i stay at people's
places i don't get the five-star hotel
maybe i'll
do like a two or three and then like
i'll look for deals so my money goes a
long way and then they see me eating at
a lot of places but then like i might
not eat three meals i might eat two
so then my budget might be
less than 50 bucks that day for two
people
like the leftovers later or something
yeah or like i eat at home and then i
have friends mainly the places that i
travel to like if if there's friends
there i'll couchsurf or like um you know
i'll bring groceries and i'll eat at
their house like a lot of this stuff
can't be done and in the play that i
have like i don't go shopping a lot like
um
i play at the beach or i play in nature
and then which is free 99 yeah oh yeah
and then i i think like just there's a
lot of fun that you can have if you're
social people can show you around or
like just the other day um i flew to
kauai on a on a private plane i saw that
yeah because uh one of our fans he's uh
uh he's he's learning how to be a pilot
so if you don't mind risking your life
and getting flown by a 22 year old you
know crazy [ __ ] how do you trust
this person because i know the rigorous
training that pilots go through and he's
trying to survive too yeah that's how i
always see it but
by the time they can put people in the
plane like they've been through so many
hours and then like i kind of watch what
he was doing and he's so thorough that
i'm like okay like he's
i wouldn't trust a 22 year old maybe
driving but flying i know that the
training and hours
it's way more than driving school so oh
man that was one of the things we
slightly talked about was getting our
pilot's license that'd be cool yeah yeah
but i think i became i don't know what
happened but i think i became kind of
scared where like now i can't even go
off-roading because i get really scared
you're on the ground dude i know i know
but like i just like a weird fear that
even in the plane now like i've never
been scared on a plane and i i i think i
was flying to miami like on a red-eye um
and it was crazy turbulence and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm just gonna go to sleep because
i was so scared and i could not sleep
the entire flight because i'm like we're
gonna die
but did you die no but i don't know
where it didn't don't but did you die
um but i don't know where it came from i
just have this weird phobia that just
hit me out of nowhere prime menopause or
something bro what the [ __ ]
you really trying to have a [ __ ] bad
day
one of our friends got his license
and we met him up in utah for his wife's
uh birthday
and that was the sickest thing ever
because we drove right like normal
people and it was like in the middle of
nowhere was like a really cool camping
nature town it's next to bryce canyon
so everyone took like at least seven
hours
to get there
and there's a local airport there
and this guy's like i'll meet you guys
there i'm coming from montana and he
just flies in to this tiny ass airport
that only has one hanger
and he says when he was calling in
because you have to talk to the air
traffic controller no one was even there
no one was even manning it he's like
whatever whatever my plane i'm gonna
land or whatever no one even received
them so he's like [ __ ] it he lands and
then some like honky tonk dude in
overalls with no shirt underneath and a
chihuahua
and a chihuahua tucked into his overalls
comes out and he's the guy that man's
the airport he's like hey you're not
supposed to be on the tarmac or whatever
yeah cause we we didn't know so it was
uh for the birthday so we wanted to like
receive them yeah so i just
and the gate opened so i just drove
straight into the airport onto the
airstrip because i saw his plane come
down like [ __ ] yeah he goes hey you
can't do land i was like oh [ __ ] my bad
with this [ __ ] chihuahua here
but yeah he was saying that like when
you're driving i mean when you're flying
through the air
you can just cut across states and you
can see um people that are living off
the grid that have built their own
little homes
like in between mountains and stuff and
i'm like man that's a whole different
way of exploring
like what we already have it always
blows my mind when i see that because
i'm like how did they get the building
materials without the roads and
everything like that
carry it yeah like what yeah they have
to fly it in yeah have you seen that row
um uh i don't know i'm sure they're all
over the [ __ ] country but it's a
community that has instead of like a car
garage they have a a hangar for you yeah
it's in florida they have a i think they
have it everywhere right um they have a
well there's a community in florida
where the whole neighborhood every house
has an airplane yeah and the [ __ ]
garage is massive and it's just the
regular looking house it's crazy that's
[ __ ] cool we can all get our pilots
do you have your motorcycle's license
we we have to do that together yes i do
you know in this room you know who's the
only person that has a license still you
yes what happened to yours
uh something happened when i took the
test and i failed
he took it on accident too and i'm the
right i'm the guy that rides the most
too
so [ __ ]
okay so last question all right um
what's in store for 2022
what is in store
wow
damn it you haven't you're just in the
present moment well unless you have a
ton of [ __ ] i know for a fact that i um
i'm focusing a lot on like
staying here in vegas cool yeah cool for
us and um in hawaii that's time we have
to build the business there and really
i'm gonna be doing a lot of the stuff
that i've been dreaming of like oh i've
always talked about spearfishing or like
getting better at surfing so a lot of
the water sports stuff right so it's a
work-life balance of like checking off
those dream lists of like waking up in
the morning go surf and then go to work
do some stuff there and then um you know
fly back film our jk news whatever
whatever
but as
time progresses i think
you know
well for one the relationship is gonna
grow between me and hannah and then like
we're gonna be more serious about like
life building and whatever and like what
we should do together yeah and there's a
lot of things that i think we bond
working with each other like you guys
know like you become closer working with
each other in certain projects right
like this yeah yes or no yeah but it's
um
people say don't don't do it but i'm
like but that's how i bond with people
like i love working with people yeah and
then so
if it's the right person it's perfect
exactly
the maturity needs to be there for sure
and and i think um
we we tested ourselves in a lot of
different things
and for one is like she's a designer
she creates clothes all that stuff and
it
really got me to like be more
comfortable with like experimenting with
art again and creativity and like looks
and things like that so i think we want
to try
for the rest of the year just try making
clothes and things oh so cool
that's so cool accessories and just see
where that goes you know are you going
to buy a bunch of fabrics and have a
little workshop and try to make things
yeah like i want to try making hats i
want to make jewelry i want to make just
whatever and we have a sketchbook that
we just started and we're just like
writing out ideas making sketches and
then so like
i don't know where that's gonna go but
it's really i think it's just gonna be a
whole year of exploration yeah and
creativity and just playing yeah fun and
you're such a good artist
like you draw really well
um and jewelry has been something you've
been talking about for years yeah and i
think i never
did it on my own because
you know like new things without you
know a mentor or whatever
it's really hard especially if you have
your time like filled up with other
stuff like we're doing comedy and all
this other stuff but like if you have a
pro right next to you and they've been
through it and they're like oh yeah
that's easy you just gotta do it like
this it's like oh cool now i could have
my ideas come to life way quicker yeah
how fun okay so jewelry clothing spear
fishing um speaking of spear fishing
kalila told me colorado river is
apparently a big spirit no [ __ ] a river
yeah she says it's 40 foot deep and i
think it's only an hour drive from here
so we should all go she said she likes
going there too all right yeah yeah i've
already i'm already setting up plans
with her to go to the philippines oh i
want to go there
i mean you are what the [ __ ] did i go by
myself i don't know you thought it was
gonna be a girls trip yeah like i wanna
go i'm like yeah it's [ __ ] expected
that you joined dude really that's
awesome yeah yeah i think if things were
open i travel more
but yeah really it's like now so i had
this dream um for the past several years
of like okay
how i want to live my life what is the
ideal life for me and then well for one
i like being semi-nomadic right where
like
i like
being in different environments i've
been in la all my life and i always
dreamed about
uh studying abroad or like all this
stuff that i wanted to do in college
that i couldn't because i was like broke
and then i was like in la all my life
and so
people i noticed like a lot of our
friends too that's moved to la they come
to la to find themselves or like they
come to to to do something different
i'm so comfortable there that i'm like
every time i feel like i learn a
different version of who i am is when i
leave
so i'm like
and then also i've always wanted to like
live a little bit in japan a little bit
in europe and whatever and get a
bunch of variety throughout the years so
now i'm establishing routes where i have
like homes in different places
businesses in different places and i
think that's what's exciting to me is
like kind of like dabbling into this
maybe some real estate here
and
no specifics right now because it's all
in the beginning building phases but
that's the most exciting thing
yeah that's hella tight sounds really
exciting and fun
yeah it sounds really really fun i'm
excited for you yeah um so when this
happens in in january you're gonna start
in hawaii first you're gonna start out
here
i'm just trying to be selfish man i
[ __ ] miss you i'm just trying to hang
out so i'm just trying to figure it out
i'll be here most of january so we get
to play
and explore and whatever
and then
um
probably most of spring i'd be in hawaii
and then who knows from there but for
sure
you know like it also depends on on how
much hannah's here too because she's
like i want to make clothes for jill i
know we talked about this stuff yeah
so she's like i'm itching at work on
stuff yeah
when she's out here she's not working
because her style is like
i'm gonna be on productions working and
then like now i'm a [ __ ] off for a month
and do whatever i want that's tight and
i always envied that like i looked up to
her like dang like so you work for a
week and then like you're so cute what
the [ __ ]
you could do the same [ __ ]
it's just recently that i did she's been
living like this for so long right and
then she says that
the give and take is that
she's all we got she's always at the
will of a production company and they're
scheduled it's unstable for us like we
can build a foundation roots and wealth
where like
because we don't take time off it's like
we built this legacy whereas for her
she's free she could do whatever she
wants but she still needs to go back to
work and make more and then she runs out
of money yeah yeah yeah there's no
momentum yeah she gets to build so it's
like a she's like a carney she's like
working for the circus and then for us
we are the circus yeah
dude that's how it works that's how you
guys are just gel so well yeah so it's
like it's kind of cool because now i'm
learning
to be even more free and
and and and like what do you call it
like
mobile which i always wanted to do and
so since she's used to that she her
standards are actually lower than mine
amazing so i'm like
this is awesome like i'm the one that's
like we should have a better hotel she
goes
why and then i'm like oh my god these
loud ass neighbors i can't sleep and she
goes but it makes it feel like there's
life around us how cute
i love her
oh my god what a positive person man
yeah that's awesome it's [ __ ] tight
so it just feels like oh yeah now i have
an adventure buddy and then it's kind of
cool sharing that you know like being on
the go
and then
it's like i realize we're both similar
in a way where we moved around a lot
so
it's not the place that makes us feel at
home it's the people and it's like
if you're you you ground yourself with
the people that you're around so like if
you go
i don't know like like let's say you
know we moved to vegas but then it's
like you guys are the unit that's what
makes the house not the not the house no
yeah yeah yeah like having you here now
like you don't live here like um like
like we're barely i'm barely getting
used to getting like i love vegas but
i'm i'm still getting used to this whole
lifestyle change um but having you here
now it like it feels like homier again
yeah i was just telling us that too like
when we did the whole norcal trip we did
a whole road trip and then like um by
the time i got to your guys's house i
was able to sleep
cause like
we're always on the go it's it's like
high anxious whatever like work we're
sleeping but then like i think new
environments new things we're all a lot
of stimulus yeah we're excited it's not
like a negative thing but it's like even
excitement in a positive way can be
stressful because it's a lot of emotions
yeah and then by the time we got here
like i crashed so good and i was like i
felt like
cozy you know yay
that's awesome that's [ __ ] tight dude
i'm so [ __ ] happy for you again i
hate the compliments i hate it i don't
mean to shower you with this [ __ ] but
i'm just really excited for you you're
in such a good place you're so happy
you're freer than you've ever been like
uh uh like it just feels like this
really dope connection like there's this
cool joe vibe here i'd [ __ ] love it
whatever you're doing keep doing it um
hannah's [ __ ] radish [ __ ] um
yeah i'm just happy you're here thank
you very much thank you so much for
being on this podcast um i mean not that
you had a [ __ ] choice i know what
right thank you we wanted you to be here
i'm like i know you guys are coming so
so which day you're going to be on my
pocket i didn't even ask him i was like
what day like you're not going to say no
but like what day can you do it he was
like okay
that's just what we do and it was funny
you texted me yesterday because you're
like oh [ __ ] did i not yeah because did
you were you waiting for me and you're
like where the [ __ ] is joe
i was gonna re-confirm with you
yesterday but i was gonna do it via text
yeah uh our conversations kept going
from like text to
instagram and then when i went on the
texts i'm used to talking text i'm like
did i never send this and i doubted
myself and it was like no it was on
instagram and i'm like oh my god thank
god what the [ __ ] is happening but no
thank you for being here this is [ __ ]
dope um and thank you so much we'll
catch you guys next week
bye peace